Wow we are up close and personal
Oh, no. Hi, My name is Grace Helbig if you did not know now you know your life is different now welcome! Drag queens are the most amazing species of human in my opinion
I've tried to do my own drag queen make up a couple times
On this channel in the past, and it has gone well and not well. So I thought let's keep this
mediocre train going. I tweeted out asking you guys what sort of drag queen look should I try to beat my face into today and
Overwhelmingly so many of you wanted me to beat my face into Trixie Mattel who I love so much
I'm like out of breath because I'm so excited about this. Her makeup is so extreme it takes drag queen to this like cartoon
Barbie
Dolly Parton weird level
That's so fun to see so I'm going to try to
make myself look like Trixie Mattel which is
So much easier said than done. More so than that, I'm going to try to do it without watching a tutorial
She has tutorials online of her makeup looks
And I'm not gonna do that I'm just going to try. And on top of that handicap: I'm only using drugstore makeup whoa!
So one of the first images that came back was from Buddha 9 6, and this image of Trixie Mattel is just kinda perfect for this video
so this is what I'm going to try to turn my face into
- I'm so sorry in advance Trixie. I'm so sorry. Okay, okay. We're okay
I'm going to use this bandana to pull my hair back. Oh god. I don't even know how to start
I'm going to put a base layer of foundation on. Let's make our canvas as blank and monotone as possible
This is like a selfish video because I just wanted to go buy new makeup at the drugstore. This is L'oreal's Infallible
Total coverage foundation. Okay, let's just put some foundation on. Oh shoot. I brought out a...
primer spray from NYX. Well thats f**cked Thanks for being here
Smear it on. Your face is a biscuit and the foundation is that gravy
Start with the eyes. Covergirl Katy Perry kitty-what? I have this Katy Perry for covergirl kitty whisper like white?
Eyeliner? I'm gonna just start doing that try to... s**t oh I already bent it. Dang it.  I need a
Pencil sharpener. Going well! We're just gonna
Start putting white in the tops of our eyes and underneath where we see that Trixie has done this. Alright
Ohh-kay, here we go yeah. Ow ow ow. I'm also trying to do this like relatively quickly because I bore myself. Now we're gonna go underneath
This is a great face. Basically we just covered the entire area that
Indicates we did not sleep well last night. Oh, I have slept for a thousand years
And keeping with the theme of all of us being drugstore purchased
products, I'm trying stay within that theme, I have this Bronx colors contouring palette
That's got like this white and Bronx colors isn't available at drugstores, but it's the same kind of like price range as drugstore
We're gonna take a dirty eyeshadow brush and just blot it on a makeup wipe
and then clean it on the palm of her hand because we are
Just a scumbag and then we're gonna take this white
contouring shadow
Cool, let's see how this sets this illuminating powder wow
This powder also has an essence of iridescence, which should be the name of an R&B group: "Essence of Iridescence". Not totally matte
Okay, so it's a bunch of like shades of brown that go up shaded up into her eyebrows. So this is Revlon's Colorstay
Oh, which is Gwen Stefani is doing a whole line with Revlon right now?
And this is part of her line. Look how very Gwen Stefani
She's just a girl in the world
So I'm gonna use this brown powder in here. Take a brush that we're gonna clean on a makeup wipe
dry it on their palm. We just want like this basic
Outline that goes into our nose we can blend this out. Don't worry
Oh look at that! This side of my nose is like, "new year new me" and this side is like
What year is it? Cinch that nose!
I'm going to take a fluffier brush and sort of blend it out a little bit
I'm just gonna put some more brown powder just sort of in the
socket. Take some of these neutral like yellows and tans, and sort of blend that into the browns. You're just to soften it
That's okay
We're gonna go back in with the-this
Angled brush and our dark brown and we're going to make sure that there's a real delineation between the white and the brown. I have
Eyebrows stuff on my eyebrows from earlier today. I'm gonna wipe that off with the makeup wipe. Okay! Now
We're gonna put some white at the top
white goes below our brow bone
That looks like a thing! Trixie's eyebrows go above and beyond. So I'm gonna try and matte out this
part of my eyebrow with foundation and then just like draw in more exaggerated eyebrows.
Ohh, whoa! Ooh also, I should use this white on
Duh, okay
Ok this did not blend well. Let's - oh god.
Let's keep going! Oh, this looks great. Basically we use a covergirl eyebrow
filler thing you have to fade the eyebrows into.. Ohh, oh that's perfect mm-hmm
Oh, how flattering! You want to look like you got electrocuted?
But only in the eyebrows. The worst part about doing your eyebrows.. one is the fact that you're bad at it.
And then, two, try and repeat it on the other side. This is so bad!!
I'm gonna brush this with an eyebrow brush. Well, that's insanely terrible. How did this get this bad?
It's just getting so much worse. There's a phrase, "quit while you're ahead"
But when you don't feel like you're ahead you don't need to quit. Hold on, I'm gonna really try to fix this
Okay that feels a little better to me. I'm gonna put some powder on, see what that does
Uh,I'm- I can't-uh. Okay! Eyebrows are good enough for now. Oh this has been a journey. We're gonna start
What are we gonna do now? we have the big swooping?
black eyeliner!
I have this covergirl
liquid liner that I don't know what it's called cuz I got rid of the packaging. It looks like the shape of like a
Siamese cat in a Disney movie. We're gonna try our best to do this insanely
exaggerated winged eyeliner and see what happens
Why did my TV turn on? There's a ghost that wants to watch Bravo so bad. Again, my eyebrows aren't- oh uh
It's creased! God dang it! Wow. Wow. Wow. These profiles are very different but both of them say, "are you okay?" Okay!
We have our eyeliner on, and I feel like f**king David Blaine just held his breath underwater for like 12 minutes for no real reason
Uh, we're gonna clean it up a little bit. Okay! Eyes are sort of.. sort of a thing now
We're gonna work on this like so bronze and pinky cheek with like the cut-in of highlights
I had this true blend contour palette from Covergirl. This is a cream
I'm gonna use this dirty dirty makeup sponge. Got these insane cheeks. Just like a Nike swoosh of color
We need some pink in there
I didn't buy a blush and the blush that she has in this photo looks a little pinky purpley
So I'm just gonna use this eyeshadow palette
That looks like we're almost having an allergic reaction to something.. Perfect!
And then we want that real deep cut line so I'm gonna take my Maybelline
Concealer in white and just cut through the cheeks
We're getting there! Lashes. Lashes are a big deal!
We got lashes on top and this exaggerated lash on the bottom, and I did something kind of crazy
I bought these
Magnetic lashes from Ardell at Rite Aid where you basically?
Put your top tier on and then you put your bottom lashes on and they connect to each other via
Magnet, so you don't use lash glue. I think it's witchcraft.. So we're gonna test it out right now. Upper lashes, lower lashes
We put this one under our top lash. Oh god this feels weird as f**k. Oh s**t! Uh, this is wrong. Oh boy.
Oh, ok, here we go. Mother f**k! Great! Why?! I'm gonna get other lashes and just glue them on my face. Hold on
I think these are Ardele's black 33. I look like I'm Marge Simpson with the makeup gun right now
They're on! They're on! They're on! We'll curl them in a second. Oh I put them on the wrong eyelid
That's why!! God dang it! It's not too bad this all looks normal and fun and great.  I actually
Really, am proud of myself. Trixie has this very signature like half lash that goes underneath
And I don't have any other lashes that aren't f**king magnetic, but I have these individual ones
And I'm gonna try and glue on and see what the f**k happens
Okay this is..
Obviously not good. The last piece that we have to add to this puddle right now
Puddle?? Giant pink Barbie doll lips. So we bought purple. Lip liner. This is Revlon's, Colorstay
Lip liner in violet rush, and we're gonna overdraw our lips and see what happens
oh, look at that!!
Okay *laughs* oh no oh no!!
She has much more of a pink lip. I bought these red ones: color charts lip powders from the Gwen Stefani line
I guess they're like eye shadows that go on your lips. Let's try it. Adding some sheen. Ohh!
Hold on! She's wearing a headband, so I think maybe if I put my headband on correctly it'll obviously bring the look together
Oh there we go. Wow, perfect. What an identical match?
Oh, my god. Also, is it weird that I think that I look like the lovechild of Katya and Trixie Mattel right now, okay?
Well there you go
there's another video of me trying an iconic drag queen look aka just ruining the foundation of
The artistry that this drag queen has built for themselves. I'm so sorry Trixie
I really tried. I mean I don't think it's that bad
I just don't like looking at my own face if you liked this video give a thumbs up
And if you want me to attempt other iconic drag looks
Please leave them in the comments down below and do not forget for the sake of
Everything that is right and wrong about this look to subscribe to my youtube channel. For this moment in time
I'm making videos every Tuesday and Thursday so click that Bell notification and the subscription link so that you are notified when these videos of
Such art.. go live
I don't know
The viewfinder I think is giving this look more justice than what I'm looking at
in this mirror down below. Because what I'm looking at this mirror down below is just
So bad and sad and wrong and not.. it is.. just is so bad. I'm sorry Trixie